thanks a lot for this opportunity it's a
it's absolutely a delight for me to
really come here and talk about india
and the whole idea of competitiveness
and entrepreneurship in india
so what i'll try to do today is that
i'll give you a quick rundown on what my
idea about competitiveness in india is
what do i think about entrepreneurship
there
and so on and so forth uh so i'll speak
for about 40 minutes that's the
thing that has been instructed to me uh
so if you really look at
entrepreneurship what is it all about
the way i actually look at it it's a
very simple kind of a concept wherein we
are saying
that we use land labor and capital we
bring it together
and we actually create something unique
out of it so and this is also the very
basis
in terms of like how do we actually use
our resources for creating
competitiveness in the world so one of
the basic pillars that we are really
talking about
is about factor conditions how do we use
these factor conditions
and how productive those factor
conditions are in fact when we really
talk about enterprise
or entrepreneurship the critical factor
is that if i'm able to use these factors
well if i'm able to make them productive
that's when the whole set of things
start functioning that's when wealth
actually starts getting created
of course there are a lot of theoretical
underpinnings which i'll not really
cover here for the talk but then if you
really look at it
there have been people like peter and so
on and so forth who have really talked
about the idea of
entrepreneurship innovation and things
but when you talk about an
entrepreneurial ecosystem
what is it that we have to really
understand or look at the whole
entrepreneurial ecosystem has to really
talk about
number of set of things so the first one
being the policy and regulatory
environment
so the question here that we are
actually trying to delve into
is whether we actually have a great
policy environment within the indian
context so what we are really saying
here is the doing business indicators
or whether it is easy for people to
really come into india be
entrepreneurs or they are actually
supported within the system at all or
not
this next thing is talk about funds
where the funds are available what is
the
whole situation about capital whether
the vc markets function
and so on and so forth the next thing
that we are really talking about basic
level infrastructure
we will get into these kind of
situations and numbers as we actually go
along
a very sensitive very simple idea in
terms of like what's the conceptual
model linking institutional frameworks
of innovation systems and
entrepreneurship and competitiveness
this is part of your course that you
would have actually done
i'll not really go into this but the
idea was to really set the ball rolling
in terms of thinking as to what are the
various ideas from where i'm actually
building the whole
talk so what is competitiveness then
competitiveness very clearly is the
productivity with which we actually use
or create productivity through the
resources that we actually use
in fact it's about the value that i
actually get a very simple set of
answers or questions here
when we talk about a software engineer
in india
versus a software engineer in united
states what is the difference
the difference is very clearly in terms
of productivity that we actually see
the productivity of a software engineer
in india is close to about thirty
thousand dollars per year
but when you talk about software
engineer in the united states it's close
to about half a million dollars a year
that is actually a very interesting
number that we can actually look at
and quite interestingly when you talk
about the iit industry
in fact when we talk about the whole
idea of information technology
or the whole idea of entrepreneurship we
do talk about i.t
industry in india and i would like to
really set the ball
set the tone here that a lot of times we
actually make a mistake
in terms of thinking that iit is the
biggest thing that has actually happened
out of india but that's a huge mistake
that we actually make a very simple set
of numbers what are the number of people
who actually work within that industry
the number of people who are actually
impacted by the iit industry in india
just about half 5 million
in a country which is close to about
1300 million people
5 million actually has no bearing at all
in fact you can actually say from a
world point of view five million seems
stunning
but from an indian context five million
is actually a very very small number
so if you really look at these ideas and
just delve deeper into what this whole
industry is all about there's something
very interesting
when you talk about competitiveness of a
nation i always say
in fact this is a construct which was
which has been talked about
and professor dasher also talked about
it that there are three stages in which
how or how the the whole idea of a
nation goes
or how economic activity grows so it is
about factor conditions
the next is or you talk about
factor-driven economy
to innovation to a manufacturing driven
economy or an efficiency driven system
to an innovation driven system so let's
try to understand india per se
what is india all about india is clearly
a factor driven system
it's a factor-driven economy because
what we are doing there is
we are talking about labor arbitrage
very clearly
it is about labor arbitrage because i
think what happens is
so when you are talking about labor
arbitrage that also has a huge bearing
in terms of what kind of
entrepreneurship would actually come
across or what kind of entrepreneurs
would actually be there or what kind of
systems or what kind of business models
is what we would actually be seeing over
a period of time
quite interestingly when we talk about
these factor driven
system that we are actually having in
india what we are saying is that we are
it's a battle between created prosperity
and inherited prosperity
because india is very clearly as i say a
battle of inherited prosperity when we
are trying to use the people
but we have not really migrated to the
next level in terms of how
the whole idea of a country can actually
be how we can actually create wealth
for the people let's try to look at a
few set of numbers here
the numbers are absolutely very
interesting if you really look at the
world economy what is the impact
of the world of indian economy on the
world economy or what's the percentage
india is just about 2.9 percent of the
total world's gdp
china is nine and a half percent and
that's how the difference is
and when you talk about united states
it's close to about 26 percent
european union is close to about 24
so what we are seeing here is that a
country which is about two and a half
percent
so what is it that is it is actually
doing and 2.4 percent with about 20
of the world resource in terms of people
that means
that whole idea of per capita income or
it's actually a very very poor country
from a person-specific basis and when
you talk about this that means it's
about entrepreneurship which is going to
go into a direction
which is hugely different so if you
really look at it
when you talk about the competitiveness
these are the various factors that we
have to actually understand and look at
and what are these factors that we need
to look at very clearly it's about
sophistication of company
operations what is the kind of diversity
of firms what kind of state of cluster
development actually exists
whether there is some kind of an
interaction that actually happens within
diverse set of firms whether there are
enough clusters that have actually got
formulated
over a period of time but then of course
what we're really seeing here is coming
to a very interesting set of
understanding
that we have to build when we talk about
comparativeness it is dependent on four
distinct pillars
the first one being city factor
conditions we did talk about people
we did talk about labor but let's not
try to understand infrastructure itself
because once we understand
infrastructure then we actually
understand
that what is it that we are really
talking about or how doing business is
actually an issue
or how creation of enterprise could
actually be a challenge
when you talk about the indian context
there's something very interesting
in the indian context the average speed
of traffic is close to about 35
kilometers per hour
that looks very interesting but that was
a figure for 2001
but if you really talk about the figure
for this year it is close to about 25
kilometers per hour
that means movement of goods movement of
people
is actually a huge challenge so when
you're actually talking about these kind
of set of numbers that means the cost of
doing business
increases exponentially and people are
not really talking about it
so what is it that we can actually do
with these kind of
situations when you talk about power the
most interesting city in india
say gurgaon or bangalore more
specifically gurgaon
which is supposedly one of the it hubs
it actually has close to about
eight hours of power cuts on an average
in a day
today if you're actually trying to do a
comparative statement between
which place should i actually locate my
unit if i actually do a comparison
between
gurgaon and alabama you might actually
decide that let's go to alabama
because the cost of doing business in
alabama is actually much lower
the overall cost of doing business so
when you actually talk about
competitiveness
the question is it just cannot be run on
what we would actually call as labor
arbitrage
you have to really talk about something
else you have to talk about innovation
which is a little different you have to
talk about value addition which is
higher
and let's try to understand
a few set of examples here we are
sitting in
the hotbed of technology here and one of
the most smartest companies that we
always talk about
is apple and when you talk about i
always ask a question
then why is it that india has not been
able to produce an apple
in its country or why is it that we
don't have a skype in our country
or why is it that we do not actually
have a yahoo in our country
why is it that it all happened out here
because the
kind of people if you are actually
talking about engineers who are
definitively the kind of people that you
would want
for creation of enterprise especially in
the area of technology
1.1 billion engineers every year
that's the number of engineers that
actually come out in that country
or pass out in that country 200 000 mbas
so if you're really talking about these
numbers here what is it that we are
actually doing with them
what is it that i that these guys are
actually doing in terms of productivity
in terms of the way they're actually
engaging themselves so what they're
effectively doing is that they're
what we would actually call as being
actually in a place where they're
actually becoming cyber police
it's a fairly derogatory term but what
we are actually saying is that they're
just simply doing a fairly mundane work
of something something very interesting
that they would find
or whatever but it is not high value
added and when we talk about this whole
aspect
we have to look a little deeper as well
so when you talk about these numbers
it is simply true that it is not only
about technology it is actually
happening across the board it is
happening across different sets of
products as well
when you talk about clothing or apparels
what is happening in apparels
there's something very interesting that
happens within the apparel segment
quite a lot of the perils are actually
being made in india but they're actually
being sold in the united states with a
multiple of eight
that means the minimum multiplying
factor on the price point
from the time of the the transfer price
from india to the
shop floor is eight times what does that
actually mean
that means the power of branding that
actually is functioning very very well
can we actually create a brands which
are absolutely stunning
because at the end of the day when you
really talk about
uh enterprise entrepreneurship what is
it that i need to do
i need to actually talk about
intellectual property i need to talk
about innovation
or i need to talk about branding and is
any of these things
really actually happening within the
system if it is happening it is
happening to a very limited extent
but there are opportunities and there
are options which are absolutely big
of course the drivers of productivity
these are the drivers of productivity
that we would actually talk about
quality of overall business cluster
development
to policy coordination and so on and so
forth but coming to this whole
interesting thing when we talk about
india
and when we have to talk about
understanding india from an enterprise
perspective or entrepreneurship
perspective
i cannot look at india from a big lens
of saying just one country
we have to understand that india is
actually different locations
it's a different reality it is at least
29 different states
it's a big vast country so when you
actually talk about india you have to
really discern it
at multiple levels of geography and when
we talk about multiple levels of
geography
that means i have to understand it from
the perspective of
states or provinces and districts or
what
you would call as counties out here we
have to really go deeper and understand
what are the positives in a various set
of locations
or etc but coming to this very
interesting slide which i thought i
should share here
we were talking about those numbers in
terms of like how india is actually
performing
and what is the impact of india on the
global economy this is something very
interesting again
so if you really look at it where is the
manufacturing sector for india right now
it is just about 15 of the total gdp of
india
that we are actually seeing so when you
talk about make in india
there is a possibility but the question
is going to be do we have the right
infrastructure
for doing it but discerning the
prosperity in india
a little deeper this is something very
interesting
so when you talk about india growing at
a rate of about eight percent or nine
percent
on an average where is it actually
happening or where is it growing
and this becomes a very important factor
in understanding
of india is actually moving ahead over a
period of time
the numbers here so there are something
like eight or nine states which are
growing at a rate which is greater than
eight percent and the most of the other
states are actually laggards
they're actually on the left and you
would see that so when you're actually
talking about locations which are doing
well
or beating the whole growth trajectory
that's where a lot of activity is also
getting centered
in fact when you but then of course
there are those aberrations there is an
aberration called bihar here
which grows at about 12 but with a per
capita gdp
which is just close to about 200 or
maybe 300 dollars
in fact an indian rupee that is close to
about 17 000 rupees which is close to
about 300
and of course then there is a state of
goa whereas there is a state of delhi
wherein the per capita income is greater
than 140 000
rupees but what does this actually mean
that means this is a very strong
indicator of economic
activity and economic activity
agglomeration
but before we actually go into those
numbers there is something very
interesting that i thought i should
really talk about
quite interestingly when you talk about
understanding a country
there is something the whole idea of
creative class
what is it that we actually do with our
talent
what about technology what about
tolerance in fact when you actually talk
about the creativity index
that we actually do for the indian
cities and indian states we actually use
these step
three paradigms and this is where we
actually get some very interesting
numbers
in fact there was a very interesting
debate that happened recently
president obama during his visit to
india had actually said that india
should be a little more tolerant
he actually said that i'm not even and
fairly rightfully so there are issues
that we really need to actually tackle
and we actually look at these set of
indicators to understand because
if you really look at it locations which
are able to accept weirdness
are the locations where agglomeration of
economic activity happens
when you actually talk about this
location that we are actually sitting in
what is one of the biggest reasons for
this location to be
one of the hotbeds of innovation because
we have actually been able to accept
weirdness in people and then that is
actually what happens
in fact when you talk about a place like
india if you're not accepting that
weirdness
activity is not going to happen it's
always about the creative set of people
who drive change it's always if you
really look at it
the artists the designers or other set
of people who could actually come
together
with scientists and engineers or doctors
to really give you the solutions
there's a very simple construct that we
always say it is about the medici effect
that can i actually bring in two schools
of thought together
to really find an answer for a problem
so is it going to be biology coming with
physics
or biology coming with business to find
an answer of course that's the way the
world is actually going to be
so it's about agglomeration of different
sets of people
at a certain location if that is not
happening then of course
things are not really going to be a
hotbed of innovation you might actually
end up into a system
which copies when you actually talk
about india
and if you really go to the cities or
understanding the creative economy of
indian states
this is how actually india looks like in
fact if you really look at the numbers
maharashtra is one of the states
which is ranked fairly high on the
creativity index
and this is a state which contributes
close to about 17 percent of india's
gdp and in fact when you talk about
maharashtra per se if you'd start
discerning a lit
a little deeper or going a little deeper
you would find something even more
interesting
the just six locations out of these out
of that state
or six cities out of maharashtra
contribute 90
of maharashtra's gdp that means it is
the agglomeration of
activity that is happening at locations
and that was driven by weirdness
because what are the locations that
things are actually happening it is
happening in mumbai
mumbai is supposedly one of the hotbeds
of activity
wherein we are able to accept people of
different sets of
uh tastes ideas views and so on and so
forth pune for that matter and that is
where it is happening
the whole emergence of bangalore it
actually happened because of that
so when you are actually talking about
this very interesting thing
what we can actually see the number of
factories and competitive intensity and
diversity of firms
so if you really look at it wherever we
actually see a huge diversity of firms
that is where we are also seeing some
entrepreneurial activity
that is where we are seeing that yes
there is
some kind of innovation that is actually
happening that means that there is of
course a significant effect
of clusters actually getting formulated
but going to the states a little deeper
when i say when you actually talk about
countries you always say that countries
have to be adjudged
from a bigger perspective of saying they
are actually factor driven or factor
different economies efficiency-driven
economies
or innovation-driven economies if you
really look at the states as well
they have to be bifurcated into that
aspect itself
so india cannot be looked at under one
single lens it has to be looked
at from the lens of saying that of
course there are states which are factor
driven
there are states which are efficiency
driven there are states which are
innovation driven and you would actually
find that economic activity and
entrepreneurial activity
actually gets agglomerated at a certain
level
let me show you the numbers here or some
statistics here
so if you really look at the innovation
driven when i say innovation driven
it is actually you might even say to me
that is force fitting that methodology
maybe yes
but the question here is that it
actually gives me a very strong
indicator
as to how or where entrepreneurial
activity is happening
or where it is actually where where
people are actually looking at doing
something
significantly different so if you really
talk about the state of maharashtra
the state of gujarat maharashtra and
gujarat combined contribute 44
of india's exports that's something very
very interesting
so two states contributing such a huge
major impact
to the economy of the country tamil nadu
is where the various sets of clusters
have actually emerged
the whole i.t cluster the whole idea of
the automotive cluster
which actually happened there because
there is a lot of economic activity
that started happening there but there
is something very interesting
that we have to understand and look
deeper into it's about untangling the
linkages between city competitiveness
and economic growth so if you really
look at it
this is a very interesting slide that i
thought i should share
so if you states with a high degree of
urbanization
tend to have greater gdp or
state level gdp itself so that means
urbanization is a very important
indicator
of how economic activity can actually
get created
so when you actually talk about this
whole system in india wherein they say
oh yes we have to build the right set of
cities
we have to build the smart cities it is
being driven by this idea itself
because urban areas create that
agglomeration effect bringing those
people together to really create
something interesting
of course the development of indian
cities this is how the cities are
actually there
there are a number of cities that are
happening within india but if you really
look at the numbers
53 cities with a population of over a
million
and then of course expansion of cities
of metropolitan regions this is how
these places have actually grown and why
i'm actually talking about these cities
for a simple reason
these are the cities which have actually
shown a very strong
indicator towards reform firm
formulation or firm creation
we have looked at those numbers but i'll
actually come to those numbers as well
but a very quick snapshot in term like
how the creative economy of cities or
how the snapshot looks like
or how various cities actually look like
how the ranking actually comes in
so if you really look at these numbers
or if you really look at this index what
you would find is
that the bangalore bombay delhi this is
where entrepreneurial activity is
actually happening
in fact when you talk about a place like
bangalore everybody knows bangalore
everybody knows bangalore for a simple
reason that is where
there are a very interesting set of
people who are coming together to create
the next set of firms we are not even
discussing or debating whether they are
creating something significantly
different from the west
are they actually creating world-beating
products but yes they are creating some
unique business models
they are creating some unique
propositions say the whole idea of snap
deal
flipkart they were effectively started
from there
so that is what we are actually seeing
or an evidence to that factor
and when you talk about competitiveness
cities and we are seeing
cities which are creative they are also
becoming a little more competitive over
a period of time because
acceptance of different views has an
impact on performance or
on the competitiveness of a city so
these are some rankings which i thought
we should really look at but coming to
the challenges faced by entrepreneurs in
india
what is it that we face in india today
what are the challenges that we are
actually seeing
quite interestingly it's about funding
are there enough and more people who are
willing to seed fund
is there that ecosystem that is
available to actually do something
what is the cost of failure are people
scared enough to fail out there or not
what
do i actually have the right set of
skilled people in fact something very
interesting
you know i i actually met some people
from england or united kingdom recently
and they actually made a very
interesting or startling statement to me
they said in india there are close to
about
30 crore people that is about 300
million people
who are able to speak english i was
absolutely surprised
because that figure is horribly wrong
for a simple reason
that is not even the number of people
who have gone to school
so if that is a number so what is
happening is that we are also looking at
numbers
in a distinctly wrong way we have to
look at the right set of numbers
the whole definition of what is it the
skilled labor
what are the number of people who are
actually able to do something the right
skilling
the whole idea of right skilling and
then of course
hard infrastructure we did talk about it
infrastructure is a challenge
but the question is that within the
problem itself rise or arise
the biggest set of opportunities in that
country and that is where you are seeing
some unique activity
let me give you an example here if you
really look at
the cities the cities actually see a
very interesting problem of
traffic and this is how business idea
actually did happen and it is becoming a
very interesting
model for delivery of drugs to people in
the cities today
in fact the question is that if you
really talk about a city like delhi
on an average a person is going to be
stuck in traffic for about two hours
right if somebody has a heart attack on
in the car what do you think is going to
happen
the biggest possibility is that he's
going to be dead
how do you solve this problem you can't
solve the problem of traffic
right because i think one of the ways of
really looking at it would be let's
solve the problem of traffic
oh you can't do it because the number of
people who are there in the city
you have 27 to 30 million people who are
living there you can't dismantle or
dislodge them
you can't really move them out of the
city so you have to find a solution
or an entrepreneurial solution to really
taking care of this problem
so what do you do how do you solve this
problem if any one of you has been to
india
you would realize that there are those
roadside kiosks from where you can
actually buy cigarettes
in india cigarettes are sold in packets
of one and twos
so what do you do you actually keep two
medicines sabitrate and aspirin
at those kiosks so if somebody feels
that he's actually having a heart attack
he just goes to that location
picks up aspirin and has it the
mortality rates are expected to go down
by 97
for people who are actually going
through a heart attack or a cardiac
incident
a very simple solution that's what the
kind of innovation india is actually
requiring today
that is what we are really looking at
you have to solve the problems
of people i think a lot of times we
always say it's the high-tech industry
versus the low-tech industry
but is there something like a high-tech
industry or a low-tech industry i
absolutely disagree with this very
paradigm for a simple reason
there is nothing like high-tech industry
and low-tech industry it's high-tech
firms
or low-tech firms because any industry
for that matter
can actually be high-tech the question
is what is the kind of value-add that i
actually do with it
and of course the local conditions will
actually give you some impetus to really
find solutions
but that's the way it is a very simple
idea
when you talk about israel what does
israel do
in terms of agriculture i agree in terms
of agriculture israel actually did one
of the most stunning
uh what you call innovations and that
was about drip irrigation
so that was actually a very smart
innovation which changed the way we were
actually looking at growing food
we were actually talking about saving
water so it was a very simple innovative
solution
so it was actually but a lot of people
could actually say it is not high tech
but then it was a very smart solution
for the world similarly when you
actually talk about shoes
italians actually make or sell the most
expensive pair of shoes in the world
probably they are actually made in india
but you've just not been able to create
a brand around it
so this is what the whole world is
actually about how do we actually look
at those systems
but coming to these numbers when you
talk about mapping the conversations
around
innovation ecosystems this is where a
lot of excitement is actually happening
india is actually right now at the cusp
or at the point where people are talking
about this as being the entrepreneurial
location
so there are about 15 000 conversations
happening here usa is about 92 000 china
is about 25
000. and why does this actually make
very big sense
it makes huge importance for a simple
reason that this is where
people are looking at presenting
solutions to the world but unique
solutions
to unique set of problems moving ahead
so this is how the conversation are
actually happening these are the few set
of figures you can actually look at
so if you really talk about india when
they talk about entrepreneurship
they talk about india they talk about
bangalore they talk about bombay
they talk about new delhi when you are
in united states you are also talking
about india
right now as an entrepreneurial hub
why for a simple reason everybody
understands the next set of innovations
that are going to happen
are going to be driven from there a very
simple idea here
when you say like why why is it actually
carrying such a huge set of
uh impact because the next set of things
that are going to happen to the world
or the next set of innovations are going
to come from the less developed world
or what you would actually call as the
low resource settings or countries with
low resource settings
a very simple idea here would be that
when you talk about economic objectives
and social objectives
they are actually going to come together
they are going to be a very simple
situation wherein we would say
that we are going to actually solve
social problems and that is where
enterprise creation is going to happen
and this is actually driven by a very
simple paradigm that the world tomorrow
will actually need to have market-based
solutions
and what are those market-based
solutions those market-based solutions
would actually be
about solving the problems on ground so
if i talk about the problem of
sanitation
in india we are going to be looking at a
market-based solution
if you talk about the problem of water
you are going to be talking about
a market-based solution and that is
where you would see a lot of innovation
happening
over a period of time so when you say
innovation and entrepreneurial activity
in india
it is going to be driven on business
models it is not really going to be
driven on
technology it is going to be about this
delivery of services
in fact a lot of times and when you talk
about delivery of services it can
actually be riding on a technology
platform
but at the end of the day it is going to
be about solving a distinct social
problem that we are really looking at
and we are seeing more and more impact
on more and more evidence of that fact
i'll talk about those examples as we go
ahead
then of course there are some numbers
that i thought
what are the total early stage
entrepreneurial activity in india
why people are actually discontinuing so
if you would actually see
one of the biggest things is about
access to finance do we actually have
access to finance in india
in fact this is something very
interesting which i thought should share
when you talk about new firm density
which is a very interesting proxy of
entrepreneurship and
things india is actually one of the
lowest hong kong is a country
or hong kong is a location right as a
distinct location does
more firm formation or firm registration
than india that means there is right now
a severe
lack of entrepreneurial activity that we
would have actually liked
of course whatever i say here you might
actually end up saying that the
corollary is also true
the corollary could be true for a simple
reason somebody couldn't come to me and
say
that india is intensely entrepreneurial
yes india might actually get categorized
as intensely entrepreneurial but the
question is it is not about
what you call in a in a formal setting
it is activity which is actually
happening
within the informal setting you could
actually be a
vegetable vendor for a small location
you could actually be a
cigarette vendor in a small location you
are not able to scale up
so the challenge that we see here is
about scalability
can i actually create solutions within
the informal system
which can actually be scalable over a
period of time
the global entrepreneurship index so if
you really look at it what are the
this chart clearly depicts as to uh what
what is it
how is india actually performing on
various set of indicators and this is
where it is
so in fact opportunity of startup one of
the lowest ranks
and that is one of the challenges that
we're really looking at but then quickly
moving into this whole idea of i.t
industry in india
i did talk about the it industry but the
challenge here was
that it industry should not be really
seen as a proxy for something which is
happening
or which is a very unique situation
quite interestingly when you talk about
it as i gave you the numbers it's about
those productivity numbers
of american software engineers versus
the
indian software engineers we need to
find solutions
which are going to be uniquely local
quite interesting this is where i
thought there was one of the most
intense entrepreneurial activity that
has happened in the last
20 years or 30 years and this is about
the automotive cluster
of course this whole automotive cluster
was actually seeded
somewhere in the early 80s but that was
actually happening for a simple reason
that you had suzuki that was coming up
so when you actually had suzuki coming
up that is when people started creating
unique set of firms which are able to
actually become part of the cluster
and that is where they actually or we
started seeing
huge agglomeration of firms happening in
distinct set of locations
and of course over a period of time we
actually found
that there were five distinct clusters
which were actually moving up
and those five distinct clusters were
what one was of course you actually had
the haryana based
manis or gurgaon cluster we actually had
the emergence of
chennai as a cluster for automotives we
had the emergence of
and pune as the other two clusters and
of course now
we are actually seeing the emergence of
sun and there's a location but when you
actually see
in fact why am i talking about clusters
here the whole importance of clusters is
that it is if you are able to seed an
enterprise or if you are
able to actually have a pillar firm or a
fairly
big enterprise who's willing to come in
we can actually call it as an anchor
firm and there is a lot of
entrepreneurial activity that can
actually happen around it
and the government is actually looking
at that whole proposition in fact for
the first time
in the history of independent india
there is a first administration
which is talking about entrepreneurship
in india which has actually made it as
part of the budget itself
in fact until now what we would have
actually seen that we were all talking
about job creation
right we were all talking about
institutions which were created for job
seeking
so today we are for the first time
saying oh we have to be a country
which is going to be talking about job
creators rather than job seekers
for the first time in fact the
government of india allocated a
budgetary thing
in fact it was something very similar to
what happened in the united states
this is the same thing that happened in
this part of the world
the government of california actually
allocated a huge budget
in the 1950s for entrepreneurial
activity
and that's the same kind of a thing that
we are actually seeing within the indian
context now
can the government seed something can
the government actually support set of
entrepreneurs
that we actually require and then of
course there are those numbers that we
can actually find
but what is it that we are actually
looking at easy access to equity capital
the businesses are entrepreneurial hubs
but the biggest question is
what is the cost of failure can i
actually accept
failure within the indian context the
whole cultural paradigm
of failure and acceptance of failure
what is the present union government
doing as i said
they are actually for the first time
allocating a budget wherein they've said
they're actually going to allocate close
to about two billion dollars for
entrepreneurial activity
but moving very very quickly on this why
is entrepreneurship important for india
why are we even talking about it because
if you really look at it
where is wealth actually generated
wealth is always generated in firms
wealth is always generated by new set of
ideas it's not generated anywhere else
because if you want to actually reduce
the level of disparity in that country
if i want to actually have a great
quality of life
for my people what do i need to do we
need to actually talk about building an
entrepreneurial culture we need to talk
about
enterprise creation where there is no
other way
that you can actually talk about wealth
or wealth creation and
equitable distribution of wealth because
if you really talk about there are two
systems that we are talking about
here the system of about this whole
socialistic idea
that we will distribute wealth it never
functions it never works
the whole idea of the capitalistic
system when we say that let's actually
get people going and let them actually
create a unique sense of activity or a
unique value proposition
that is what is going to change the
world and that is what i actually said
as well
it was about that the whole set of
social
objectives and economic objectives will
have to come together
the honeybee network is a very
interesting network wherein we are
actually seeing some indian enterprises
or indian innovations
which we are seeing of course there is
also a huge debate that is happening
right now
on the idea of jugaad jugaad innovation
and things jugaad is a very interesting
word
but has a huge negative connotation
because it is about shortcuts
and so we have to understand that it is
not about jugaad it is about frugal
innovation it is about
understanding that how can i actually
create a solution in a low resource
setting
in fact very interestingly when you talk
about low resource setting
bollywood is a very interesting example
of how it actually functions within a
low resource setting in fact why i
actually talk about bollywood here is
i wanted to give an example from
hollywood there was a very interesting
movie
that was made recently called gravity
which was a multi hundreds and hundreds
of millions dollars of
vertical money was actually spent on
making that movie
but there's a very interesting thing the
cost of sending the mars mission in
india
was actually less than the movie called
gravity
that's a clear-cut evidence of what we
call as frugal innovation
and that and i'm not even saying it as
shortcuts it is actually about frugal
innovation it is about
trying to understand that how can i
actually get the best out of resources
that i actually have moving next
mumbai dabbawalas this is one system i'm
sure you must have actually heard about
it this is one of the greatest
delivery systems that you could have
actually seen in the world
this is absolute six sigma infinite even
better than that
there is a system wherein you are
delivering food to various
offices and they don't get it wrong at
all and why does that actually happen
because they have created processes
which are absolutely stunning and it
started about 50 years back
they've not gone wrong even once
so what we are really looking at is we
have to really create a system
for india than anything else of course
there is this whole india's angel
deals ecosystem that actually exists
which is for the
sake of argument if you really look at
it there is a lot of activity that is
happening around here
there is bangalore mumbai and the whole
thai
construct that is happening but the
question is we have to go beyond it
people will have to think
that they have to fund aspects which are
beyond technology
they have to fund businesses which
actually solve social problems
of course the number of pe deals this is
something very interesting over the
years
there is about 795 in 2014
and this is something very interesting
of course this is a figure from bain
there is another figure that is actually
floating around for another
consulting firm wherein the figures are
hugely different but now the question is
whichever you want to actually believe i
like to believe this one
and that is where it is and the overall
angel venture capital np financing
ecosystem we are actually seeing some
very interesting numbers here
there is of course center bridge
partners alibaba tiger and so on and so
forth that we are seeing
but very quickly just to skim through
these numbers i want to actually come to
some conceptual
underpinnings but when you are actually
talking about why is india lagged in
creating an entrepreneurial ecosystem
very quickly lack of proper
institutional support
lack of access to mentors do we actually
have people who can actually support
that activity because
even today when we are standing here and
talking about enterprise creation or
entrepreneurship in india
people want you to get jobs people want
you to actually go ahead
and get a jobs out of colleges they do
not want you to actually become
entrepreneurs even today
and that is a predominant view there is
of course a lot of activity that we are
seeing
but that is not the dominant view of
things
is there a link between competitiveness
and innovation
and of course enterprise creation and
entrepreneurship of course
because if you really look at it
countries which have actually
had huge level of enterprise creation
and entrepreneurship
they have been fairly innovative and
they have been fairly competitive over a
period of time
so if you really look at it
this is where india actually is and this
is where united states actually is
so what we are seeing is a clear
evidence that
innovation is actually driving
competitiveness wherever you're actually
seeing a lot of entrepreneurial activity
that does drive competitiveness if you
really look at this
very interesting set of numbers patents
by the uspto
this is again a very interesting proxy
of course patents are a good proxy for
innovation
but then the question is where is united
states and where is india
this actually gives you some very
interesting set of numbers or factors
of how things are in fact if you really
start looking at the per capita numbers
this is a very stunning reality of what
the world is all about
in fact this is where again this was
some very interesting work that we
actually did
we tried to see as to how patenting and
competitiveness at the state level are
actually correlated
so we found a very clear evidence that
of course
when you actually have large or high
patent activity in a certain state
they are more competitive states and how
are
how are we actually trying to understand
the competitive state so states which
actually have higher per capita gdp
so of course that is the uh what i call
uh dependent variable
also and that that is where we are
actually trying to find an
answer to it similarly the trends in
patenting in india
but what if a country lacks a robust
happy regime in fact one of the things
which is stalling comp
entrepreneurship is about ip
intellectual property
can i actually protect my intellectual
property if i do not do that then i will
actually see a very clear-cut evidence
of distortion and access of information
intellectual capital and so on and so
forth when you talk about
you would actually face issues within
the demand conditions
people will not really get the right set
of products you would see a lot of
duplicates coming and so on and so forth
in fact if you really look at it it
actually distorts the whole idea of an
industry structure as well
in fact this is a very interesting thing
that we did for the pharmaceutical
industry
but we found that if you actually want
people to come in and be
doing something innovative out there
then
if there is not the robust ip regime
they would actually want to be going
away from that location
so this is one of the factors which
becomes exceedingly important
that we need to actually look at
similarly ip system of an mnc versus
that of a typical generic player
india today is actually very at a very
interesting stage
wherein we are a very interesting
generic uh
io vertical pharmaceutical manufacturing
system
so there is a very huge difference but
then this is actually happening because
we are not seeing
uh drug discovery that is actually
happening within the indian context why
does that not
actually happen either we are not really
the funding a lot of research
or probably we are not even actually
seeing uh something in terms of
what you call people investing from even
the west
or even wanting to go there and give the
new set of medicines
in fact does lack of trust undermine
comparativeness in fact
this is one aspect which i really wanted
to touch base on
if you really talk about competitiveness
and trust this is one of the most
important factors which
drives enterprise creation if i do not
have trust in the system
then yes enterprise creation can
actually be very lower if i do not
actually have a system
wherein we can actually have a very
robust system or where i can go to the
court of law
and get immediate help then things stop
functioning in a very interesting way
and this is where the diamond actually
gets distorted
or the industry or the diamond in the
within the country gets distorted and we
are seeing that
impact of trust in the value chain of a
firm trust actually has a huge
implication on the activities of the
firm as well
because this when i say trust it is
actually a very interesting proxy for
corruption so can we actually look at
those systems
and can it actually have an impact on
entrepreneurship
this is again when you talk about
pharmaceutical industry the trust could
be the missing element
which could actually have an impact on
entrepreneurship itself because what is
the kind of activity that will happen if
there is lack of trust
that means transfer of technology is not
going to happen
and if transfer of technology is not
going to happen if i am not able to
protect the ipg
ip of various sets of people i cannot
further the idea
i cannot work with them and the newer
set of ideas don't really come through
you have to start from a base level and
that is what what is
happening within a lot of industries
that we are seeing
in fact quite some interesting numbers
on high-tech manufacturing in billions
of usd
so if you really look at india india is
just about 14 billion even today
and when you talk about china it is
about 365 billion
so it's a fairly small number if we
actually say that high-tech is one of
the
factors that we need to look at
high-tech manufacturing is percentage of
world
but then if you really talk about role
of private sector in economic
development
this is what we have been really talking
about that it is a private sector
which is going to create wealth which is
actually going to create a situation
wherein distribution of wealth can
actually happen
and then of course what we are seeing is
that we would
see a lot of firms coming in in terms of
creating local infrastructure that is
where the public private partnership is
also coming in
but then something that i've actually
been talking about
social objectives and economic
objectives have to come together i would
like to talk about some
very interesting examples i would like
to talk about the example of mother
dairy
mother dairy is a very interesting
business wherein 83
of its money that they actually get from
the from the consumers
are actually given back to the farmers
that means on 17
margins they are able to run a system
which is fairly efficient
they have been able to create a business
model which is profitable
when 83 of the money goes to the farmer
that means there are distinct
possibilities of creating systems
which are unique to that part of the
world but those are the solutions that
we actually require
in fact when you actually talk about
hindustan unilever they have created a
distribution system
with women within the villages wherein
23 percent
of their distribution infrastructure is
run by village women
that's a very interesting very powerful
thing that they've been able to create
but that is where the whole construct of
shared value comes in how do i actually
create shared prosperity
how do i actually get people to really
come in and find entrepreneurial systems
watsalia is a very interesting hospital
system
wherein they've been able to create 19
hospitals in south of india
with 100 beds each but talk about a
certain set of disease segments only
and operate in tier 2 and tier 3 cities
so what i'm coming from is
there is entrepreneurial activity that
is happening but the most significant
entrepreneurial activity is happening
with
beyond the technological systems that we
really want to talk about
the entrepreneurial activity is
happening wherein we are talking about
business model innovations
and nothing else if you really look at
it
there is something very interesting that
happens it's about distribution it's
about end use how do i actually
create products for end use what is it
that i'm actually able to do
so if you really look at it it's all
about when you talk about tata swatch
or purity these are very interesting
water cleaning or filter systems that
have actually got created
and but that was done for a local region
which has actually created a lot of
innovation a lot of
aspects where the quality of life of
people has actually improved
so we have to go beyond that thinking
and really move ahead
but last point which i really wanted to
say once again
in a competitive economy we have to
understand one thing
that there is nothing like a high-tech
industry or a low-tech industry it's all
about firms
and nothing else and that's what india
actually needs as of today thank you so
i meant thank you for a really
thoughtful uh presentation a lot of
things that
you hear about when you talk about
entrepreneurship you really did not
mention much today
and yet i think some of the things are
really very profound in this kind of a
view
you talk about you'll hear people talk
about needing to create
success stories needing to create
well you know how would you look at that
as a factor in
india now are entrepreneurs celebrated
in india
well of course we are seeing that
entrepreneurs are becoming celebrated in
india
we are seeing that yes of course when we
actually see snap deal happening or when
we are seeing some local
manufacturers of cell phones happening
they are getting celebrated
but of course there is also a side story
to it the side story is that they are
actually a replica
of something from here itself it's not
about being fairly innovative
when we actually have a kind of
enterprise called micromax which sells
telephones
but the sourcing is actually happening
from china yeah so of course they are
able to create a brand but they've just
not been able to do something unique or
different
so the question here is yes there is
some celebration but
i i think we are still far away from
what we need to actually achieve
in the next 10 or 20 years but i do
think that it's a really good point that
the opportunities are in solving social
problems and
in really getting you know the needs of
the country met
that's a very profound point
a lot of that reminds me of the bottom
of the pyramid discussions from uh
cj prahlad some years ago
do you think that india's market will be
the main driver for
entrepreneurship going forward or will
you have more international activities
aiming for global markets very clearly i
think it's going to be
india's requirements which are going to
drive activity there it's going to be
india's requirements which is going to
drive a lot of things
if you really look at it why is it that
people want to come to india it's it's
because you're actually talking about an
opportunity to solve something
because when i say that within the
problems reside the opportunities in
india itself
you have a bad infrastructure what do i
do with infrastructure can i create a
cold chain that's where enterprise
enterprise can actually happen when you
talk about unilever that's a very
interesting example of creating a
distribution network
in villages itself they are able to
create a distribution network which is
supremely efficient
when you are able to sell products in
650 000 villages
so it is about local conditions that is
where things are going to happen
in fact when you talk about something
like an activity for
an i.t enabled services firm or whatever
i do not see it as a big thing because
its
impact on people is fairly limited yes
of course it does create a very powerful
brand
but it does not really have a huge
impact on people on the ground
maybe in terms of solving problems and
giving services yes but in terms of
distribution of wealth no excellent
let's open the floor
you said that without trust transfer of
technology will not happen i believe
that's the exact quote
and i'm curious um both u.s and european
corporations
um you could argue didn't have a problem
with trust
in china so did china sort of break that
model for india
because it proceeded it and there was so
much ipf that occurred there
or is the circumstance just different
for india
okay when i'm actually giving the whole
idea of trust i'm very specifically
talking about the pharmaceutical
industry
but i'm actually talking about the drug
discovery and so on and so forth and
healthcare setup
i've also understood one thing that when
you talk about uh
ip issues within china wherein you
actually had software
piracy and so on and so forth there is
always a jury which is out which says
whether it was deliberate or whether it
was something else there's always been a
debate that was a deliberate thing or a
ploy of the software engineers to really
create a network effect
because if i actually get stuck into a
certain operating system
then there is something that's going to
happen so probably that was a deliberate
thing because that's the understanding
or debate that we always have in india
at least within the software segment but
when you actually talk about trust
i believe trust is always an element
which has to happen
and i think when you are talking about
china there are systems when apple
manufactures in china
there is no evidence of the fact that
they have been compromised somewhere
yeah because you might actually have
shumi which is coming in but it is a
replication or rip-off of
what apple does but there is no evidence
to see that
somebody has been able to blatantly copy
anything out there
so china did manage that their system
was very very powerful
in terms of managing it and that is
where the whole structure of india
versus china also happens india is a
democracy with a court system that
that takes time at points in time you
have to go through that process
china could actually manage things much
more swiftly and much more faster
the trust and other things are all been
lagging for a long time there
so what what specific things that you
see that there is a little momentum of
entrepreneurship that you see right now
caused that effect what was not there
before what was there right now that is
causing a small momentum
you know the biggest change that i see
in india today
is about accepting that you have to
solve social problems go beyond the very
thinking
of just having something to do with it i
think we were just stuck in that whole
i.t bubble for 20 years
for the first time i'm actually seeing
that people are wanting to go out of
that id bubble
and say yes there are opportunities
beyond it as well
there are opportunities beyond software
firms or beyond
what you call call center firms and so
on and so forth today people are saying
i am going to create a social venture
and we are they are already talking
about impact investing they are going to
create social ventures which are going
to solve problems we are already seeing
the evidence for that for that in fact
very interesting example which i would
like to
share here there's an enterprise which
is run by a guy called jordan castle
called vision spring in fact he found
that 200 million people in india
actually need eye glasses 200 million is
a huge number right so how what do you
actually do so he tried to create a
business model
wherein he's able to give a pair of
glasses for a dollar to people
and still makes money out of it so
that's where
the whole action is because when you say
that
you can actually go on to say you know
the number of uneducated people in india
are huge
we have 400 million people who are
uneducated but that means yes there is a
possibility of creating impact
either by way of technology or creating
something see creating that whole id
platform to really deliver a service
which is very much required
so that is where it is people are
looking at solving those problems
that is where opportunities are coming
up that is where we are celebrating the
people today
i think india has moved on and saying we
will celebrate the social enterprises we
will celebrate people who help us solve
the problems of the general people
then to just talk about simple things
yeah
so there's a great deal of interest i
think
in the silicon valley community about
what's going on in asia
and including a lot of people who would
like to invest in asia
and so forth could you comment a little
bit on the roles of the diaspora from
india that
is here in the us and also just how can
people here
take advantage of the opportunities in
india in a positive way i'm not saying
you know any kind of exploitation
oh in fact when you talk about diaspora
i i was just looking at a few numbers
a couple of days back 22 billion dollars
of worth of uh what you call money was
transferred to india from diaspora
in the united states in the last one
year so that's a very interesting
investment
cycle that is actually happening of
course whether they're in investing in
enterprises or they're investing in
uh whatever you call in property we do
not know but they are certainly sending
that kind of money out there
the diaspora is now becoming more and
more interested
in terms of investing in newer set of
ideas they've also started understanding
i think in the last couple of years we
are seeing a very interesting or a
dramatic shift
when the diaspora believes that we need
to solve problems
of the people there and they're willing
to invest in those businesses
uh so they've gotten out of the i.t
bubble certainly for sure in fact i was
actually with
i don't mind even naming a person i was
with a guy called shaker nursemen who
was
one of the most prominent people out of
the diaspora in the united states
he is today talking about solving social
problems in india
he's saying can i actually create a
business model for really talking about
sanitation within villages can i
actually create a model
wherein we are able to create a village
level
solar infrastructure which becomes
self-sufficient
wherein once the investment happens the
cycle gets created to really
run it through so today we are actually
talking about those sort of ideas i
think
for the first time in india we are going
back to what i would call as the
gandhian
idea of economics the gandhian idea i
always say was about
creating local resilient structures
and that is what we are actually seeing
so create local models of business
probably they could be they are not
scalable but they are at least
replicable
because within the indian context you
cannot create scalable models you can
create
very smart replicable models
so in this area a lot of people have
talked about the
new middle class in india how would you
say the role of
the quote middle class fits into this
and first of all in terms of defining
middle class but
you know like defining middle class in
india itself is a very interesting
paradigm for us for a simple reason what
could be defined as middle class here is
not
middle class uh in the indian context
uh in fact i still remember there's a
very interesting folklore that goes
through that when honda came into india
uh their definition of middle class was
oh they looked at some numbers and it
said
that india actually has some million
people who are in the middle class their
estimate was that they are going to sell
about 100 000 cars in the first year
it never happened for a simple reason
the very definitional aspect was
actually different
because what we were saying middle class
in early 90s
was hugely different from what we were
actually looking at but having said that
i think there is going to be a lot of
wealth which is going to get generated
at the top end of our top end or top 300
million people
but the opportunities are not are
anyways there they are getting exploited
but i
see the future set of opportunities
happening at the bottom 900
000 million people people because that
is where if i'm able to create a model
wherein i'm able to serve those thousand
million people can i actually do
something interesting
in fact let me give you an example here
gsk for that matter
gsk in africa galaxy smith clean in
africa has
just really turned its whole business
model on its head
there was the in fact i just met the ceo
recently and he actually said something
very interesting he said
that you know in africa we are saying
rather than making a million dollars out
of 10 000 people i would like to make a
million dollars out of a million people
so today people are talking about
pushing products to a larger humanity
larger set of people
now talk about what you call high volume
low margin models
rather than anything else so that is
where the opportunity is
yeah if i go back and i think about what
we featured here in previous years we
had
the ceo of redbus one year and
red bus was basically amalgamating the
system for purchasing bus tickets
because it used to be every company's
tickets had to be purchased through
separate channels
anyway they were bought by a chinese
company
a year or two after he came and spoke
here um
does anybody know what happened to red
bus after they got bought by
the chinese company what happened
they were there and that's the uh the
new company called as
ibbo that's a chinese company as you
said but they already have
some kind of these kind of like
ticketing mechanism
sales yeah they offered a price and then
they bought it absolutely
so that's that's how they were being
parked so they're continuing in india
it is continuing it is still a
well-known market there as per my
knowledge
okay so it's there but they know like as
we said that uh the founder is no longer
continuing
okay so funny is now sama who is the ceo
there he has actually now become
somebody who's investing in social
enterprises and things so he exited out
of that enterprise
the enterprise still exists but quite
interestingly i think
redbus was picked up for a very
interesting proprietary
platform that they'd actually built
which was something very unique for
india
and that's where the valuation was yes
sir
you have placed the quite heavy on the
trust
as a very key element now with the
infrastructure
situated in india that means before you
really have a very good
infrastructure built up then the trusted
among all the scheduled people regions
in india
is not going to be very helpful for
entrepreneurship
i would somehow disagree with your
assertion on this
and i have to disagree with that
assertion and i disagree for a simple
reason
if i go with the idea of creating
infrastructure in india it's not going
to happen in the next one decade it
might actually happen in the next two or
three decades
so what do we actually do now how do we
actually create
systems when we are able to uplift
people
so exactly so you are actually going to
use
maybe telecom devices and it has become
ubiquitous in india 900 million people
actually used
telephones today in india and mobile
devices so can i actually create
elements of engagement
around this and of course that element
of trust wherein i'm not doing any
breach
of contract or whatever which is
actually just which is going to stay
and which makes the system move forward
because
that's the way it is it's something like
the uber that actually happens here uber
is all about trust it's about
a simple guy who comes in and creates a
model and just takes it there so are we
actually in a position to create those
set of things in india infrastructure is
not going to happen immediately we know
that
i think we have to talk about things
which are beyond infrastructure
because if i stay with that battle then
i think we would lose that battle we are
definitely going to lose that battle
um i was curious how easy it is to set
up a business
in india because i've heard stories it
could take nine months to get a
telephone installed and you know you
have to maybe
know people in the government or bribe
them or
to to do these types of things so do you
work with the government to improve
these
the red tape okay i think the
what you're talking about was probably
is a 10 year old story
it's not the story for today today you
can get a telephone or a telephone
connection in less than an hour
right even if you're a foreigner who's
visiting india you can actually get a
connection at the airport itself
in terms of formation of firms it has
also become supremely easy right now
if you go by the doing business
indicators it says it takes 89 days but
we have also seen
that if you're actually wanting to start
an i.t firm say especially an e-commerce
firm
you can actually set up the firm in less
than two days
so there are systems that are in place
we are moving into that direction
so for what you call to register a firm
is not becoming an issue to doing
business is not an issue
when you talk about corruption itself i
don't think corruption is something
which is stopping people from doing
something
or to actually become entrepreneurs
corruption could actually be there at
the higher system or a higher level
but or in fact when you actually say
corruption itself i have to talk about
this
thing that corruption has actually seen
it it's always a win-win situation for a
lot of people
so corruption on the street in terms of
bribing a police officer or whatever
could actually happen but it is not
really doing something which is killing
you
so that that is where it is i'm not
trying to defend corruption what i'm
saying is it is
not really stalling the system actually
i'll
i'll independently vouch for that
because there was a study of corruption
across different
economies in asia not too long ago and
central government corruption almost
none
uh local governments where you have to
you know
talk to the local security police or
whoever right
that that was happening but i think that
the real issue and this this survey was
about five years ago so it's getting old
the real issue was that just the legal
system is very slow
and overloaded and because people are so
careful the courts are so careful in the
way that they administer the law
there was something like a case load
waiting to be heard of
over you know 20 million cases or 30
million cases or something like that
this was
a few years ago oh yeah i don't remember
the numbers but yes
what you're saying is absolutely right
so it's just about the legal process
yeah which could take a long time
because of the overload that we actually
see there
but then hopefully we would be able to
manage it over a period of time
and how processes could actually happen
because today we are talking about
higher number of judges
and so on and so forth so that that
change is bound to happen
the change but from previous governments
to support
really employment increase to the
current government's support on
entrepreneurship
how is that playing out concretely what
kind of
real differences do you see you know
like at least
the present regime is just about a year
old yeah so we don't see any evidence in
terms of numbers which can tell me that
there is
a whole huge shift in entrepreneurial
activity but at least
if i see the kind of buzz that we see
the kind of
talking points or the kind of coverage
that we see in the media we see that yes
people are becoming interested in
enterprise enterprise creation and
entrepreneurship and more so in the last
couple of years
so there is that movement that is
actually happening but for the evidence
i think we still have to wait for a year
or two to for some for some data to
really come through
in terms of like the investments that
the government is doing uh what is the
kind of impact that's happening yeah
because of that i i think that
impressionistically last week at tycon
the uh very large um conference on
entrepreneurship put on by the indus
entrepreneurs
um was a much more upbeat feeling than
i've seen
in many years oh yes and
very positive and a lot of people really
interested there were something like 3
000 people there
so this was down in the santa clara
convention center
go ahead ed uh yes sir off to you
um i just read this this morning um
india
basically has the largest number of
expats around the world 14.2 million
that have remitted 70 billion dollars in
the last year back to the old country
um that's an enormous amount of wealth
that is essentially
in productivity that's not directly
impacting india
many of the other east asian countries
especially the asian tigers
had a sea turtle type program where they
were encouraging
folks that had come out to the west and
picked up educational skills or business
skills to return
is indian government thinking of
something similar is that likely to
happen
i think i i do not know what the
government is thinking about it but i
can just tell you as to
what is the anecdotal evidence to this
uh
if you really see what has happened in
the last 12 to 14 months or 12 to 15
months
the diaspora is being or is getting
connected to very very strongly from the
indian government side
i think the prime minister on his
various visits has actually made it a
point
to connect to the diaspora and that is
what is happening and he's probably
doing it because he sees that there is a
possibility of diaspora
getting connected back home probably in
terms of investments
uh to really do some of what he probably
even coming back and doing some activity
out there
there are some programs that we are
seeing we have not seen the success of
it as as yet
but there are programs wherein they are
trying to invite professors who are
working out here there are so many
indian professors in
engineering and management who work out
of india also out of united states
they're trying to really get them back
as well
even for a short period of time they are
celebrating more and more
people who are living outside so we are
seeing that evidence at least
that yes the government is reaching them
or reaching out to them
and trying to really engage them in a
bigger way
yes no many times they talk about
infrastructure infrastructure you know
actually it is having physical
infrastructure is one
but using it efficiently is something
else uh just to give an example
indian ide all over the world they
streamline the processes for banks but
you go to a bank now
and you have to fill out the papers they
take forever
and that's one and second thing is uh
you go to
uh uh airport and there's a big line
there you know
they could streamline those just like
what they do in
usa and the same people the indians are
working on this automation things in
usa but why don't they you know do it
back there
and the third thing is the i i
send i export things to india from here
to mumbai it goes in 72 hours max
and from mumbai to hyderabad it takes
four days or five days because of
customs
and then the third thing is they have to
change the whole
concept of vacations if a festival
happens on thursday
they they close on thursday they have to
move it towards uh
weekends something like in america and
also they have to make a lot of
vacations
uh optional if people want to take it
you know even
like there are some festivals you know
what i'm talking their festivals like
only one person two percent celebrated
but it is a whole country gets shut down
because of uh yeah the comment
yeah okay uh first i disagree with
everything that you've said
very simple india does not shut down
because of its holidays
in fact let me actually tell you that
there are 12 holidays that the
government of india
mandates so it is just 12 holidays in a
year
i think in a country which is as diverse
as india 12 holidays for religious
reasons
is not a big issue and i think we need
to just respect that
i think it is about celebration of
diversity in the indian context
moving it to say saturdays and sundays
not possible here can i actually change
christmas from 25th
december every year to something else we
can't do it so it's very simple so let
it be that way
now the second thing that you actually
said in terms of customs
uh yes and passing through customs and
whatever
that might be actually true and quite
likely it has to be true but the
question is
there are processes that are actually
happening when you're trying to change
uh those set of things but there were
those two points that you actually said
if you can just quickly repeat that the
first one and the second one
which i really wanted to point out too
that you were wrong on that
uh uh no the the bands too
oh yes okay so opening the bank account
i think
you're talking about a time which was
probably 24 months back
i say i said bank no there must be
something that is happening there but
today you can open
anybody in india who has an aadhaar card
can open an account in less than an hour
so the government of india actually
started this whole financial inclusion
scheme
wherein opening an account for people is
not an issue at all
16 uh what you call karo accounts were
open in less than a day in india
in less than a day or in less than a
week so that means there are things of
financial inclusion which are
functioning
there are steps which the government has
actually taken
uh probably but at least at the
individual level there is a clear
evidence that there is a positive thing
that is actually happening i think to
wrap things
up go ahead a little bit this year
called giving back for india so it's
actually a mentoring program
giving entrepreneurship and skill set
what we learned in last 20 years
so you just you just said that there are
government is kind of
reaching out could we elaborate on that
maybe you can help us
no in fact when i say government is
reaching out if you really look at what
happened in the united states in
new york for the first time the prime
minister is coming and saying that let's
do something and
i can certainly tell you that there are
people have written to the prime
minister's office and they've got a
response in less than a week
and so there is a personal level
interest that is being taken right now
in terms of how we can actually work
together
and there is a clear evidence to that i
think things are changing and things are
changing very rapidly the only question
is going to be
when do we see that impact on ground i
think we're still about
four years to ten years away from seeing
that impact on the ground
right india is a grand country it will
take time for that whole elephant to
change or even move
into a certain direction but i'm very
hopeful that it'll move into a direction
which is very positive
because i started with that hope in 2015
to give back for india it's a mental
program to start up so maybe you can
help us later on
absolutely let's have a quick chat after
this okay uh
i think that the kind of disagreement we
see is an indication of a system in
change
and really it is you know different
experiences and and how things are
moving forward
the last thing that i want to remind
everyone that you had said though is it
really is private sector that's going to
lead this
right that it's really the the people
who are creating value and who are
trying to solve social problems
who will really probably have a much
more rapid change
in the current system than if you wait
for something else to change
so that's a great it's a great message
and
uh you know i want to thank everybody
for coming
and please join me one more time in
thinking i'm it for great presentation